hello everybody my name is Felix Becker
I work for source graph on the
typescript support and maybe you've seen
my github handle on some get up issue if
you're active in the typescript
community on github because I love
typescript typescript is one of the
greatest programming languages I've ever
used and it seems especially recently a
lot of people agree this is the stack
overflow developer survey from last year
where typescript made it under the most
loved languages this is the NPM
developer survey from last year we're
now 46 percent of all NPM users stayed
there already using typescript so you
got one and what makes typescript so
great and a thing there are many things
that make typescript great but the one
thing that comes up over and over again
is the tooling who makes the developer
more productive not as like a side
effect of having static types but as the
first-class goal and focus of the entire
language and you can see there as in the
design decisions and then the design
goals that the typescript team has set
out not striving for that 100 percent
correct type system but always for the
biggest developer productivity gain and
when I picked up typescript for the
first time I was absolutely blown away
by how much faster I could write
JavaScript code getting auto completion
on symbols jumping the definition on
fields finding references to functions
getting compile errors and warnings and
even automatic fixes for them even more
advanced refactorings like renaming
symbols or like converting an entire
promise chain to an async function
that's that's a very recent feature
and what's great is that all of these
features don't come from your IDE or
editor but they're open source and built
by the typescript team themselves and
shipped within the typescript NPM
package so when you npm install
typescript
you don't just get the compiler you
actually get language service API is
that provide these features and
standalone executable called TS server
that editors can run to provide these
features and that PS server is not just
a one-shot CLI command like you may know
from go has a bunch of these but it's a
long-running
RPC server that the editor spawns and it
then sets up file waters to continuously
compile your project in memory and when
the user wants to invoke something like
go to definition the editor sends a very
simple JSON message to that server
telling it hey can you find me the
definition of this symbol at this line
at this offset in this file TS server
resolves that and then sends a JSON
message back over standards out that
contains where the definition was found
and at which line and at which offset
and what's great is that TS server makes
it possible that no matter what editor
you're using whether that's vias code or
sublime or atom or Emacs or ven you get
all these features and you have the
exact same experience when you're
working on your typescript code locally
so and this time I want to take it a
step further and I want to ask what if I
could get all these features everywhere
outside of my local dev environment for
example on the millions of repositories
on github or even while review
code in pole requests what if as a
library author I could find references
to a symbol that I have in my library
and find other repositories that use
this and like maybe figure out oh can I
safely deprecated this function what if
as a user of a library I could jump to
the definition of a symbol inside
another library and get taken to that
source repository to understand the
implementation of it or maybe I catch a
back and can immediately do a pull
request and what if I could apply these
cool refractories like converting a
promise chain not just in my local
project that I have checked out but
across hundreds of repositories with a
single click online and the good news is
we can do that first step we need to do
for that is instead of running TS server
locally on the user's machine we run it
in containers and when you open a file
in your browser on github or any other
code hose or source graph comm we
connect to that server not through
standard i/o but instead through a
WebSocket of course it's not just that
simple because given that TS server is
running in an isolated container the
files of the project don't exist on the
same disk as they do when you're running
locally but instead they exist on the
Koto's and they're shown to the user
that way so we needed some way to tell
TS server that instead of looking for
the file on the file system it should
get that project somewhere out-of-band
and tears server itself the protocol
unfortunately does not support this but
a very similar protocol called the
language server protocol
may have heard of it or short LSP does
and LSP was created by the visual studio
code team to standardize a protocol that
provides these code intelligence
features basically in the same way that
TS server does but language agnostic and
I'm pretty sure
LSP was heavily inspired by TS server
because if you squint your eyes they
look exactly the same
if you don't though there are a few
improvements in LSB LSP is language
agnostic it uses the json-rpc standard
which makes it a little bit easier to
build on existing libraries for clients
and servers and improve request
cancellation and most importantly it
uses your eyes instead of file paths
which you can see here and in most cases
these are actually URLs because they
tell the server how to locate the
resource it's like a code file so if
it's a file colon your eye to serve
would know oh it's on the file system
I'm gonna read that from disk if it's
something custom like unsaved file colon
it would get that content from the
client is that files not safe yet and we
can teach the server a new capability
which is in a case of an HTTP URL it
should fetch that resource through HTTP
so when we sent the server our first
message to initialize it we tell it that
this project is not located on disk but
instead it's located in a github
repository and that it should fetch this
from this HTTP endpoint and the server
can do a bunch of things with these HTTP
URLs this is an API we build but it's
really just very plain HTTP that
could support all it needs is when you
do a get on some file in the repository
it should return that as plain content
you can do a head request to figure out
if if the file does not exist and check
the 404 status code you can do a get on
a directory - and just get a very simple
plain text listing of the contents and
you can even send Ana sep 2 2014 2 the
user accessing and github repository in
a browser and the user can do things
like go to definition right in their
browser and what's kind of cool about
this URL is that it doesn't matter
really
which endpoint hosts this even though
this is hosted on like typescript on
source graph com you could give it any
root URL of any service that supports
these basic HTTP features and it would
be able to analyze our project and since
we can construct these URLs even for
arbitrary revisions we can even do this
on pull requests on github where the red
section of the diff always talks to
server instance for the merge space
revision and the green and white
sections of the def always talk to
server instance of the head commit of
the diff
what this does not solve yet though is
code intelligence across repositories we
gave to your server access to the files
but it doesn't have any access or
knowledge of the dependencies of the
project for example if you're calling a
function and then on the return value
you're calling another method and you
want to jump to definition on that we
would need to know what is the return
value of that first function so we can
resolve that and typescript knows these
through type declaration files for
the.net crowd they're basically like
symbol files kind of and they contain
typescript function and method stub
definitions that only contain the
signatures but not any of the
implementation which makes them a lot
more compact and faster to parse and
these type declaration files are shipped
inside normal NPM packages so what we do
is whenever we detect that a definition
could not be found or a tooltip seems
insufficient we just install
dependencies from NPM and TS server is
smart enough to detect that new files
were added to note modules and consider
these now available types and we can
even be smart and since we're only doing
static analysis and don't need runtime
dependencies we can only install
packages that actually contain
typescript declaration files makes
things faster
so now with dependencies available to TS
server you can trigger go to definition
on a symbol that comes from a dependency
and TS server will return the definition
of that dependency inside known modules
the problem is this only gives us the
location inside note modules in the type
declaration file and the user who's
accessing the repo in the browser can
actually view that because note modules
is generally not checked into the
repository so to give the browser a URL
that is viewable by the user we need to
map this file path to where it's
actually defined in the source
repository so we need to figure out
where's the source of this package and
luckily the package of JSON contains
everything we need for that almost all
package of jason's have a repository
field that point to the repository they
contain a git head field which is
undocumented but it exists in npm
publish adds it when you publish a
package and it's the head commit off the
repository at the point where publish
happened and then there's the directory
field in case the packages in the mono
repo and it's not in the root which is a
an RFC to npm that was ratified just a
couple weeks ago so there's a very
recent feature but it's already being
adopted by very popular mono repo
packages so we have the repository the
revision the directory of the package
but the file still points to the type
declaration photo which does not exist
in the source repository and this in the
past is where we had to bail and did
some hacky
heuristic and was try to find that
symbol somewhere with the fuzzy symbol
match but typescript 3.3 had a really
cool new feature called declaration maps
and typescript always had support for
source maps for the compiled JavaScript
which are basically just JSON files that
contain mappings from ranges in that
javascript file to the ranges in source
files which allows you to step through
the typescript code with the debugger
instead of having to step through the
compiled JavaScript code and declaration
files are basically the same thing but
they're instead of mapping the
javascript file they map these signature
stubs in the declaration files to the
positions in the actual source and we
can read that the DDS map file to map
the Declaration file to an actual source
file and a new position and with that we
have everything to construct a full URL
the repository revision directory file
path and the new position which means
you can even do this go to definition
and jump to a completely different
repository right in your browser
now even more interesting for a library
maintainer in my opinion is to do the
inverse which is answering the question
who in the universe is using this symbol
what's AR the library and it contains a
function I'm interested in how that
function is being used or whether it's
used at all
so that's what we call cross repository
fine references and let's say we want to
find references for a symbol in a file
the steps are basically the exact
inverse of what we did for global
definition we find the closest package
of JSON to figure out what package does
this file belong to and then we need to
figure out what other repositories or
packages depend on this package
and luckily NPM has an API for that and
it's documented on Stack Overflow so
it's a raw couchdb query now you send to
some legacy endpoint and you get where
it back and very weird JSON structure
that eventually reveals the information
we need so we can use this to get all
the dependence of the package and then
for each package use the repository
fields again to figure out which
repositories these belong to that we
should search so then for each of these
dependence we don't actually know yet
whether these actually reference the
very symbol we were looking for
references for so for each dependent we
create a new server connection and we
ask the server for references to the URI
of the definition and the server
recognizes that this your I should get
references for it's not in the project
that was in
initialise it's an out-of-work space
your eye and it knows that it needs to
find this not inside the source code but
somewhere in note modules so it
basically runs the inverse steps of go
to definition it finds the closest
package.json by walking up the URL and
trying out different locations to figure
out the package name then it can find
this package insight node modules and it
searches for DTS on map files that point
to this source file that we're looking
for and once we have that we can use
that declaration map to map the position
in the source file to a position in the
declaration file so it's like a reverse
map now we're going from source to
declaration files because this
declaration file actually exists in node
modules this doesn't and once we have
this position we can send that position
to TS server ask for references and
since we do that for a lot of
repositories we then accumulate all the
results and stream them to a client so I
can say fine references on a symbol and
get stream references and completely
different repositories than this one
unfortunately it's not always sunshine
and rainbows when developing this one of
the biggest pains with this is that TS
server is very focused on this editor
use use case with very high-level api's
that provide like just the features that
you commonly want in editors like go to
definition find references find symbols
but it also means that it's kind of like
a black box that only provides this
high-level API and it does a lot of
things asynchronously like compiling in
the background and handling file watch
events so there's often no way to know
when TSO is actually done with compiling
something or when it has started to
consider new files I just added and that
can be programmatic problematic when
you're doing global fine references
where you initialize and then straight
send another request because there's no
way to know whether TS server is already
finished with compiling everything and
until then it will just return
incomplete results with no indication so
that would be kind of a wish for the
types of team to allow more hooks into
figuring out when TS server is done with
something and a similar problem with
yarn and PM given with that it's a CLI
tool there isn't really any way to
efficiently hook into the installation
process and for example filter out any
packages that that don't contain type
declarations there's some light at the
end of the tunnel though yarn 2.0
plugins should allow something like this
where you can hook into the install
process and yarn 2.0 is basically going
to be completely
in yarn 1.0 in that it's not targeting
the CLI use case first but it's going to
be API first and CLI second so that's
very exciting for programmatic use cases
and then another problem and big future
potential is in elsif going through each
dependent for global references can take
a lot of time and can be very slow it's
fine for when you just want a small set
of examples of how your function is use
but if you want like an exhaustive list
of all the references to assemble for
example because you need to refactor
them then it can really take a long time
and that's where elsif comes in which is
a very recent proposal by Microsoft it's
called the language server index format
and it's dumped by language servers and
it's basically like a cache so you can
answer
LSP requests from that index without
having to spawn and initialize and a
language server and it having to analyze
the project so that would speed up this
whole fine references thing drastically
and last words everything I just shown
is life in production and you can try it
out on source graph comm if you want to
try it out on github or another kodos
you can install the source graph browser
extension which is free and I should
have put a QR code on there and also
everything as shown is open source
source cough itself is open source the
typescript support is open source you
can fork it contribute look at the code
hack around with it
thank you for listening and you can ask
me anything
[Applause]
no question yes I'm sorry can you speak
up a bit yeah
so in the case of private repos you need
to somehow provide authorization to the
language server to access that repo one
way to do that is actually to put the
access token right into the root URI
which github supports source cough
supports that too so the public
typescript up source Capcom instance top
the TS server can actually also be used
to point it to private instances of
source graph or get up enterprise and
download private repositories and you
can also set up a private source cough
instance that holds all your private
repositories to free the trial
any other questions sorry
yeah
any other questions